and then i want to talk about my success
level my success level
is nothing like i'm very popular
but i'm not rich you know monique came
out about that whole thing about black
women not getting paid
in the business and you know maybe her
delivery rubbed over the people the
wrong way
but the facts that she was talking about
very very true
you know black female comics
don't get sponsorships like male
comics do you know kevin hart is
was selling denali's hell he needs a
step stool to get in the
but i'm a woman and i have kids and
groceries
and i feel like i could sell a denali as
well as anybody
you know you got cedric hawkins stuff
you got all these guys hawking things
that you don't see any women
with sponsorship deals i've never had a
show of my home
i've always been a guest on everybody
else's show every time and i've shot
seven pilots
chappelle shot 13 before he got to
chappelle's show
so i'll shot seven pilots of my own it
gets up here and then something happens
gets up here and then somebody say no
gets up here you get a pandemic but when
it comes to being
a black female comedian i mean is there
you've been doing comedy over 30 years
is there like a resentment or do you
see what needs to be changed or like how
to change it
like well as far as the
i don't think there's a resentment
because you know i mean i continue to
work like people like to work with me
yeah i love to work i love my job i love
to go on set
i i've only ever wanted to be one thing
and that was an entertainer i never had
a plan b
i never um you know thought about
anything else i had thought about being
a teacher
and then i got a load of these
kids and i was like well that's out
and um you know i i grew up watching
you know doris day and gene kelly and
that's entertainment and all that stuff
and the glamour and you know the
supremes and
all the foo-foo stuff and that just got
in my blood that's oh i want to do that
that's what i want to do
and i've never wanted to do anything
else and i pursued that
viciously and i have achieved that but
as far as making
big big money like you know let's take a
star is born
i'm in the movie a stars one there's
four comics in the movie a star is born
dave chappelle eddie griffin myself and
andrew dice clay
um one of the biggest movies ever i'm
nominated for academy award
but hell i'm not gaga i'm not bradley i
wasn't the main person i was just a
regular hired actor
that didn't make scale but i made a
little bit above that but you get paid
once and you don't get paid no more
until the residuals come around and
you'll make that for the rest of your
life but as the movie
dwindles in fame the residuals get
smaller you see
and i have the the blessing is i do get
a lot of mailbox money because i've done
so many films and television product
projects that every 90 days is like
check check check
but those checks range from like three
thousand dollars which i'm still getting
for borat down to maybe 12 cents for
something that i did like nash bridges
or something like that
so you know and then if you don't work
you don't there's no retirement plan for
comics
there's no health plan for comics if you
don't go into acting
you can't you know it's it's just you
know you get to be in a union comics
don't have a union
we're the only entertainers that don't
have one even a clown
has a union but we don't have one
so if a um club owner does us
wrong we literally have to take it to
the streets because there's nobody to go
to about there's nobody to protect
you
and as a woman it makes you very hard
because you got to play with the big
boys out here in these streets
and you can't be no punk and you got to
stand up for what you know is right
and you gotta demand your respect and
demand this and that and all that kind
of stuff
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips